what's the message you want viewers to
take away from after
what's the message about without giving
away the
i think i think the the yeah i mean i
think
i think the number one message is that
uh
that there is a a passion and a
belief and a support for
the pain uh from depression
to psd to you know that you're not alone
and that you know we we've gone down
this journey with you
and you know their healing can happen
and obviously it's a slow
long drawn-out process but for sure this
is
something we can all get over eventually
right i would i would actually second
that you know you're not alone
and um i know a lot of movies like to
tie everything up in a nice pretty bow
and everything's fine everybody moves on
and it's great and we're all happy and
healthy and
we wanted to just make sure that it
stayed real to the ending of
they're on the road back and they all
know it's a long road
but they're all on it and they're you
know they're in the buggy
chugging along um knowing that they're
if you're willing and a willing
participant in healing
it can happen you just have to you have
to be there
and stay present and willing to work
through it
and have people approached you after
screenings and thank you amazing
yes it's been amazing that's been
something i you know about you but i i
did not
expect that we're getting the response
and it's so nice because we made it for
people
not that critics aren't awesome and
wonderful you know it wasn't even in my
head
like oh my gosh will they like it or
what are the critics gonna
i needed to make it for people and it's
actually for myself a healing process
but um yeah and and from all different
takes from my small business
like totally out of it we were like oh
wow right because of the economy at the
time and people were losing their
businesses and their homes and their
loans and
you know i wrote that because that was
what was going on but to
hear my son had to do this and i feel
the connective
aspect to it to for people to share i
mean it's such a humbling thing
you know while i didn't lose in this
event that you're discussing
my sister did go in a car accident my
mom was like this for a couple weeks
like everything was just nope
everything's fine
right i'll find that that didn't happen
everything's we're good
a layer of denial yeah yeah because
that's ultimately what it's about and
how real
how real the situation is because it's
one of those things where
i don't know if people really are in
tune or want to address
how dark depression and psd can be
and to hear people come to us and say
my grandmother she completely separated
or my father
my and that's that's one of those things
that you
you didn't expect to connect you know we
were just kind of telling the story
for our own process and it developed
into a movie from there and then
you know actually we put in it out so
you don't expect
people to to grab you in the lobby and
just talk to you and talk to you and
talk to you about
so much of their own personal be
so helping them to heal that they're not
alone
so that's been a gift absolutely
it's been a true gift and when did it
click for the two of you that you wanted
to also be behind the camera i know you
have girls gotta eat
productions that's true and you've done
another movie before this together
but when did that click that okay let's
let's do our own projects
well that's that's funny um we did
hypocritical oath as a test run
um to see if we could do it we it's a
short it's great it's powerful but you
know we have very much a learning
process you know the camera was fuzzy
with the camera guy we hired and you
know we thought oh we'll put this
out and did really well though in terms
of just showing it around
as a sample piece i guess of what we
could do with zero
zero dollars and thought that's it
that's you know no
you know so um it was right around then
when we knew we wanted to make after to
give it uh to write something to see how
we would
perform and put all the obstacles in it
had animals kids
and um crowds no all the things you're
never supposed to do
not supposed to tell the drama and
you're not sorry
i'm like screw it why don't you know
we'll just
let's just get it over with and um
so girls got to eat was actually just my
loan out as an actor i think you know a
lot of us just have loan out
companies so for purposes tax purposes
and whatnot
and so it became our it was like that's
a production company name we're gonna
just
be able to do that and after came about
when we had some bites but they wanted
to um
yeah uh change this and change this
and change that and hollywood too much
of this look i get that for dramatic
purposes we had to
up the stakes you know you've got to
make it a little on the
up the stake side but the things they
wanted to do like no we can do better
and we can do this
yeah i think i think for us it became
i'm you know
i think more for sabrina than myself
because i
i just got caught in the wind of this so
to speak you know
this was not a an expected i didn't
start off my life going
i'm going to be a filmmaker you know
this was a
process in which i found myself stepping
up to the challenge
and it was you know the light had shined
that was it
done so the i think one of the big
things is that
the script started as a healing process
for sabrina in a medium
that she could convey it and
sort of because i never wrote before it
was a diary really
yeah and it wasn't something that we had
you know we were gonna make a film and
everything like that it was something
that started as
a healing piece and then it as it
started to build
and we started to realize that this is
our story
and we need to tell this story and
communicate it out to the world
and of course once you tap into the
creative element
right all of a sudden it's the next
thing and the next thing and the next
thing and the next thing it just spawns
i mean sabrina wrote this
it took years to get it molded for her
and make it feel right
and then she banged out two unbelievable
scripts within a month
right after that you know and i made the
mistake
of once we decided we're gonna do this
because for me it was about hitting rock
bottom
you know how do i heal myself how do i
get out of my depression and our level
of ptsd from this
home for the whole thing and um i needed
to
do something that uh you know went
because the only place is up
from rock bottom so what is that what
does that look like how would my family
react
if that happened to me because it was
very close that it did almost was me so
um
how would they react and i just sort of
built it from there to find that
dark place and only then could i see it
because once you can see something i
think head-on then you can find your way
to heal or
fix you know only see solution uh
instead of problem so that was what i
needed to do
you know to fix myself and then some
friends were like
what you're doing this and they read it
and they're like do you know how many
people
because it isn't just about that event
like i say you know we don't as
survivors
corner the market on grief we don't own
that there's a lot of people that go
through this
every day all over the world and
it needed to ultimately be about lost
like i couldn't write about a car
accident or
a murder because that wasn't my
experience i could only write about my
experience and what happened
so switching gears a little bit what
motivates the two of you to stay in this
business
what is it was it the first thing that
initially you know you'd started
modeling and
uh back i don't know in new york or
something and then transition to acting
but
what motivates you to continue on and
has that motivation
changed has it shifted there's something
i i can't speak for her because
obviously we have
i mean we it's as
as much of a unit as we are we do kind
of separate ourselves with things i mean
she's an actor and
you know my side of it is completely
different i think for me
there's something deep inside that it is
tapped into
you know that i was not aware of as i
had
gone into maturity or anything like that
i think that the
being able to tell important stories and
to be able to pull that from a deeper
place
the satisfaction is beyond the fame or
the money
or anything it's because there isn't any
of that
clearly not about that the collaborative
side of it you know was very much
this this uh thing that i was not aware
of and
it's that's the drive i mean now that
this has happened
i plan on doing this until i'm in a
wheelchair and dead and i'm not going
anywhere
so for me i think um motivation i don't
look at necessarily
motivational for me it's i am constantly
learning
yeah i get to always be expanding my
head and i'm
always in a place of creation and to be
able to tell other like our next one is
crafty
it's a craft show mockumentary dawn is a
broad comedy
and and hopefully at the same time
puerto which is a true story about a
drug kingpin you know it's ultimate rise
fall and redemption
so and i i get oh great i get to learn
about that world and i get to learn
about this world and be able to share
that with people
and you fall into these things and they
just become
something i don't know what it is maybe
it's something in our
crazies mental psyche in the hollywood
world where you
you feel so compelled that you have to
and it's despite the pain and the ups
and the downs and the struggles it's
just something that you
have to share you know that's one of the
things that i think after has taught us
and now going into future projects
there's such a
an eye-opening experience for the whole
gamut of the business but just the
the need to to share this with
other people in the world you know yeah
i just like to learn i just love
learning
every every project is different you
know
growing up i was like that oh today i'm
going to be an astronaut today i'm going
to be a doctor oh today i'm going to do
this oh you know what veterinarian
and you know and it became clear that
you know perhaps you may want to think
about you know i knew as a kid but i was
pushed to college and business and stuff
and then i came back to it so
um because i just i love stepping in
shoes
for a little that time period and
learning that as much as i can it's a
driving force i just crave it
knowledge and i get to do that any
advice for people back in rochester that
want to come to la
do it do it follow your passion you mean
you're talking to people that jump off
cliffs and figure it out on the way down
so do it do you bring a parachute no hmm
i mean live life it's not just rochester
it's
jump go for it do you follow your follow
your love and your passion and it
it'll just don't give up winston
churchill
awesome